Leonardo DiCaprio went viral during the  Golden Globes for this moment him  reacting to Lady Gaga as she went  onstage to accept her Globe et got the  real story from leo backstage after the  show and your reaction to her can you  imagine your reaction Lady Gaga is  trending yeah that's trending that's  trending yeah you see how quick it  happens I just didn't know what was  passing they that's all DiCaprio won a  globe himself Sunday night Best Actor  for the revenant this is a type of film  that you won't see coming out of the  Hollywood studio system very often it's  a major it's a it's an epic arc film and  and I I'm just so happy that it got  recognized tonight I'm happy he got  recognized I'm happy the film got  recognized because I want to make more  movies like this